végétarien je ne bois pas j'aime pas
beaucoup voir
[Musique]
45 Jean-Pierre elle Cabache arrive à
Europe 1
je reçois un avocat qui s'appelle
Grégoire Lafarge que je ne connais pas
du tout qui va parler pour la première
fois qu'il avocat de Georges Peyrol
des mises en examen dans l'affaire des
HLM de Paris je ne les connais ni l'un
ni l'autre
à 7h30 l'invité conduit dans le bureau
du journaliste
et avec cet avocat maintenant c'est plus
tibéry c'est monsieur le Président de la
République
après une conversation d'une bonne
demi-heure les deux hommes se dirigent
vers le studio
vous êtes prêts
on sait jamais comment ça se passe soit
même on peut rater des choses on peut
mal réagir on peut mettre l'invité sur
une mauvaise piste elle demande si on
est prêt mettre justement une
concentration tous les jours d'ailleurs
le jour on verra plus c'est trop vite
cette tension nous arrêterait
il est possible de voir ce qu'il y a sur
vos fiches vous avez des questions
écrites vous avez
et je suis il y a peut-être une
structure des ruptures il faut que
j'imagine en interview il y a une grande
partie d'improvisation disons que les
deux cinquièmes sont préparés
il est 8h20 Jean-Pierre
et son avocat Maître Lafarge alors vous
savez vous l'avez dit Christophe le juge
alphane c'est donc dessaisi du car de
Jacques Chirac qui était démontré de ce
qui lui est reproché merci d'être venu
merci à Georges Pérol on verra les
conséquences de ce que vous dites
après l'effort le réconfort et pour
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach le réconfort c'est
encore du sport
vous venez tous les jours ici trois
quatre fois par semaine faut être bien
moi-même pour être me sentir en accord
avec moi c'est un moment indispensable
de rupture d'isolement
de quoi beaucoup
[Musique]
et une hygiène de vie très stricte
moi j'aime bien décentraliser j'aime
bien que chacun soit responsable ce
qu'il fait partout moi je donne des
impulsions en même temps je contrôle je
regarde si tout va bien le média radio
il m'apporte
l'instantanéité c'est la peur du direct
la télé c'est l'extraordinaire dialogue
qu'on peut avoir avec le téléspectateur
quand on le respecte
vous m'attachez
voilà on y va
en tout cas souvent elle peut témoigner
[Musique]